recall. You recall >> Destiny is in uh some legal trouble
currently because he was caught. The person would not have been
doxed but for this additional information provided by >> Well,
it turns out he was trying to do age play with someone who was
already a >> So crazy that this deranged 17-year-old might
be giving Trump a third term. Guys, Trump's the president right
now. Okay, Trump is the president. America is under threat of
fascism. >> And I guess now there is confirmation that
that person indeed was underage. But this is the guy who runs
the LSF >> And I'm running for DGER of the year on December
the 3.
>> Oh no. Oh no. Speaking of my enemies, >> oh wait,
>> Destiny is apparently claiming he wasn't aware that
uh the person that if you >> you recall, >> Destiny
is in uh some legal trouble currently because he was caught
distributing without consent videos that he had filmed both with
and without consent his uh activities
with people. >> Dude, he went full cam to go in on this
guy. He went full cam to drive home the seriousness of the situation.
>> Okay. And the only reason we know about it is because
he tried to hook up with some random Discord egirl apparently.
And then in the process of trying to hook up with this uh random
uh girl,
random teenager on Discord,
uh somewhere along the way, like these videos that he was sending
to her got revealed.
He was sending around uh revenge. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Let me back it up. Let me back it up. Sorry. I was
I dropped my I left my water bottle outside my room, so I just
went grab my water bottle. >> Hook up with some random
Discord egirl apparently.
And then >> kind of true. >> The process of trying
to hook up with this random. So I believe he found her and this
will be a key correction is I believe he was spending his time
on Twitter surfing not safe for work Twitter tags. Okay, and
looking for stuff that way. Now why would one do that? Why would
one go when only fans exists when exists? When any manner many
vids exists, many platforms with known age verification exist.
Why exactly if you were somebody seeking Why exactly would you
go to an unverified
platform to seek that out? But just food for thought. Okay, food
for thought as we go along with the stream. Why would one go
to a platform with a bevy of platforms that exist that do age
verification that make sure the people are are overage and and
you can do this all safely? Why would you seek out a platform
that doesn't do that? It's a very interesting question. Why would
you express concerns about that platform's lack of security around
this exact topic and then go do that and then direct message
people who do who who post on on not safe for work Twitter and
seek a relationship with them? What you know I'm just I'm throwing
that question out there. We can throw it out there at the beginning
and we'll just think about that. We'll let that stew. We'll let
that simmer as this stream goes. Okay. >> A girl
random teenager on Discord.
uh somewhere along the way like these videos that he was sending
to her got revealed.
He was sending around uh revenge. Okay. And I think like uh some
of the aspects of that story you most likely heard about.
I covered it uh after the the >> What's up, Nacha Mama?
How's it going? >> Allegations were unearthed.
>> But basically,
>> Daddy Donald just tipped $5. What can I say? I've got
the greatest enemies. Judge me by my enemies. I told you the
left is coming. >> Was it really a revenge? Uh, no. It
wasn't leaked with a revenge motive in mind. So, you could say
non-consensually leaked. But, do we expect again colloquially
people will just call that you don't have consent to send revenge
because it's just colloquially easy to refer to it that way rather
than non-consensually
uh transmitted, right? Just easier easier in those moments.
This moment from the doctor disrespect. Oh, yeah. Hold on. And
I was told to find this and I didn't go find it before the stream
started. So I do think Matt Slice, this is an important one.
Okay, we'll open this up and we will save it for later. We're
going to continue on with Hassan, but >> that's my >> This
is Yes. XQC and XQC and Destiny talking about Dr. Disrespect.
Very
>> He's now in a bunch of legal trouble, civil and criminal
over this. But it turns out there's more to the story. There
was speculation that the person >> Dr. J,
please
make no mistake. We'll get to the merk crash out from last night
in in due course. Okay, we will get to that from two nights ago
rather. We will get to that mer crash out. Okay, we'll we'll
get that kind of content back in. Don't >> Uh he was trying
to hook up with
was underage. And I guess now there is confirmation that that
person indeed was underage. Remember those uh logs that came
out? So, suffice to say, he was trying to purchase nudes on Twitter
or he was looking at nudes people who sell on Twitter, right?
He messaged somebody, said they were hot. Um, oh, wait, we we'll
wait to get to those. But he he talked to this person on Twitter,
added them on Discord, and then pursued basically trying to get
them to fly to Miami when they're on Discord together. And for
a significant part of that DM, you know, of that DM's life cycle
of that talking relationship's life cycle, she was underage.
>> Destiny
trying to uh do age play. Well, it turns out he was trying to
do age play with someone who was already a minor or at least
according to the readily available information. >> It's
gross. It's gross.
This was Now, obviously, this is not that surprising for many
of you because uh you've probably seen uh Destiny
lowering the age of consent before, talk about how actually it's
not the femophilia and things of that nature. He's done all of
that, right? So, this might not come that much of a surprise
to you, but this seems like the biggest confirmation so far.
More leaked between Destiny and Rose. The underage girl he sent
revenge to because my parents are like super strict. Don't do
this. Don't do that. Don't go there. Don't talk too high. Well,
it would be so hard to drive you home. Oh god. I'm not going
to read the whole thing. It's insane, dude. Go watch on mute
family and kids all over the place here in our house. Aha. Yes,
ma'am. You can give me a discrete video of your little feats.
I cannot believe that Hassan just decided he was going to go
I sorry. I can believe technically Destiny did call for him to
be like 2 or 3 days ago, right? So, I do actually kind of believe
it, but it still blows my mind. Okay.
>> it blows my mind. Is he trying to is he trying to read
through to make sure of >> Yeah, you can see he's like
trying to read the stuff without his like full screen on and
he's like, "Ugh,
dude." It has now been 100% confirmed that Rose was 17 at the
time the streamer Destiny was exchanging material with her anything
sent to her prior October 2022 placing him in direct violation
of numerous state and federal
>> So this is all redacted by the way. >> Um they
found out the actual identity of the person that he was with.
>> Okay. Okay. I will say
ironically, okay, in the in one of the world's greatest twists
of fate, in one of the most
the one of the most ironic, you know, statements of fact I could
possibly make is if Destiny had just waited, okay, if he had
just waited until this person was 18
to send them the Pixie video, Pixie would have her case slam
dunk for Cardi. Okay, uh the same month Cardi went through is
the month Rose was born in. Okay. And if she if Destiny had waited
for her 18th birthday, Pixie would have the slam dunk. Okay.
>> 5. That's why he stopped asking for pictures of my feet.
I got >> I guess so. I guess so. So, yes, if he if he had
uh Cardi is the federal statute for revenge. Okay. Uh what is
it? God, why can I not remember it? Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
It is the What is it? I can't remember what it stands for. Somebody
can say what it stands for. Okay. Somebody can say it. But if
he had just waited, if he had just waited,
then he'd only have Pixie to worry about. He wouldn't have this
to worry about. Okay. >> And they found out the age of
the person, he uh it is So Cardi is explicitly It's non-consensual
images. Okay. Uh Cardi explicitly doesn't require a revenge motive.
I'm going to interchange those two terms, but if you ever ask
me to to be, you know, more specific, I will say non-consentually
distributed, not revenge. Okay? >> But it turns out she
was 17 at the time. Civil action relating to disclosure of intimate
images. Thank you, Latutigious >> It's a parking ticket.
She leaked it herself from what I can gather. Will Israel grant
him refuge?
Maybe if he
>> Dude, I saw Okay, I wasn't going to retweet bad empanada
just because of the optics. Not because it's wrong to do so,
but just because of the optics today. But he did have a banger
this morning like breaking Destiny scene boarding flight to Israel.
His
defense is that he thought she was 18, but allegedly shows he
didn't even try to verify her age despite being skeptical that
she was 18. This is allegedly the first interaction Destiny had
with Rose, a 17-year-old. The second image is an email explaining
how the image was obtained and some behindthe-scenes DG MSAD
info. If this is truly all Destiny did to verify age, he deserves
no amount of charity. You are hot AF, but 18? What the [__]
Also, one day old account. Hm. Oh well. I mean, I'm flattered.
if you wanted to. Yeah, sure. Preferably one near an ID, so I
know you're at least 18, but I understand if that's too much
info you'd be comfortable showing. Yeah, that's fine. Just writing
something on a piece of paper more than enough. Yeah. Yeah. So,
so I just want to point out, okay, if that's real and we don't
know that's real, this is an email basically explaining where
it might have come from. Okay. And I will go through and I will
I'm probably just going to go do a whole like timeline here to
explain why I think it's enough. Okay. But what Destiny ended
up So Destiny asked for proof that they were above 18, okay?
Because he knew that they could be young. He's on a platform
that doesn't do age verification, right? What he settles for
is not even that's his primary concern obviously. Okay? Or not
obviously. I would say this is more like I want you to document
in text that you are over 18. Right? That's what he's actually
asking. He did not ask for proof. He could have said, could you
send me your Only Fans? could you send me your profile on a on
a platform that age verifies?
Right? But he didn't say that.
He said, "Okay, well, you don't have to send me your ID. I guess
just send me proof that you exist, right? Something written on
paper that shows the current date and like some message to me
and and that'll show that you exist." Yes. When you ask for proof
and they don't send it to you, that should be the red light to
end it. And I believe Destiny knows this because what did Destiny
say
when Tim Pool and Benny Johnson took that Russian money despite
not having done any real due diligence? They both go, "Hey, this
seems kind of weird. Could you like show me like the organization?
Could you show me where this came from? Could you show me some
stuff along these lines?" And they basically sent him back like
uh they basically sent Tim P and Benny Johnson like garbage,
right? which is garbage fake obviously like either generated
or super written articles and profiles, right? It's the exact
same situation. Dude, this guy did less due diligence to make
sure he wasn't receiving CSAM
than Benny Johnson did to make sure he wasn't taking Russian
money. It's nuts.
It's nuts, dude. Sorry, but I will say that is all assuming this
is true. This hasn't been verified. Now I will say um
so I believe there are some rumblings around this. I believe
innuendo okay I do not have confirmation. I have not seen the
text messages but innuendo wise. So guys this is like rumor stuff.
I believe Solo mentioned the existence of these Twitter DMs as
well. Okay that basically Destiny had said hey can you show me
your ID? And then he had just moved forward without it without
getting it. So obviously shows the concern. Shows the concern
but does not actually make any real effort to verify. At least
Benny and Tim were getting fat stacks. At least it was just money.
Yeah. So again, plenty of age verified platforms that this person
could put content on, right? And Destiny's explicitly avoiding
those things. Give us your odds. Um, I'm not going to give odds.
It's just it's unknowable right now. I'm going to still say unknowable.
But I I if I thought it was impossible, if I thought it was even
like unlikely, I probably wouldn't be covering it. Okay. Anyway,
we're we're continuing. Okay. So, he's gonna keep reading these
thoughts.
>> You are hot AF, but 18? What the? Also, one day old
account. Hm. Oh, well. I mean, I'm flattered if you wanted to.
Yeah, sure. Preferably one near an ID, so I know you're at least
18, but I understand if that's too much info you'd be comfortable
showing. Yeah, that's fine. Just writing something on a piece
of paper more than enough. Yeah. Yeah,
now this is the crazy thing. This is an email that was also released
with those logs. Somebody purporting to be a part of a group
chat Destiny made or sorry, friends with somebody who was in
a group chat made by Destiny and they leaked these logs.
Now, I will say
that
I
have also
run into people telling me that they're in a group chat with
Destiny and extra stuff around his leaks was being placed in
that group chat and they had they had concerns and they had gone
to somebody outside of that group chat. Okay, I'm not ready to
tell that story yet because a lot of that is unconfirmed and
it would probably put a lot of blame on people, but I've not
with anything to do with Rose had to do with other stuff. Okay,
but I am aware of like basically somebody going, "Hey, this is
like weird [__] from outside of the from like a group
chat and I I feel super uncomfortable this being put here." Okay,
so this I have heard about this. What also happened is a part
of the Alex Gekckmo leaks here, not Alex Gekmo leaks, Alex Gekmo
is just tweeting about this. Okay, is there's essentially when
you post Discord messages, I have to go through, how do I do
this? Sorry,
he hasn't gone through this part yet.
Um, so here I'll I'll I'll pause. I'm going to pause and fill
this in right now. Okay. Because the Wait, no, we'll do the email
first. We'll do the email first and then I'll fill in after.
Sorry. This is better. This is better. >> I'm not solo.
A friend of mine is employed by Destiny. Destiny the Rword started
a server of approximately 10 people with the purpose of finding
Rose. You're correct in that they failed. He shared the attached
image with the server as well as sharing videos of having sex
with older men, other NSFW with the purpose of identifying her,
identifying the hotel, etc. She was 17 years old. In the majority
report he shared with the server, other members of the server
had to tell him that if he's going to continue sending photos
and videos of her to please blur the genitals because they don't
want to get in trouble if this turns out that she was underage.
I want to point out that this is probably a lot of the reason
that's insane by the way. Those those statements are nuts. But
this is probably very closely aligned with his belief that there's
a lot of cabal going on in the background to oppose him, right?
is that that's his natural inclination is to form a server, form
a group chat, and start scheming with these people, right? So,
I I think that this is another thing that would be showing like
projection. Again, this stuff could be verified. >> I don't
know how damning this will be. What the [__] is this?
Those features of this made me initially question the credibility
of it, but I don't believe my friend would lie as they are still
completely indoctrinated by Destiny and I have no reason to believe
that they would try to sabotage him. Close to the bottom of this,
it's partially obscured, but he says, "Aha, okay, okay, I believe
you." She declined to show proof of age and Destiny enthusiastically
accepted that. The only verification she gave him was proof she's
not a catfish by writing her screen name and the date on a piece
of paper and taking a picture with it. It looks like some looks
like a minor and declines to verify their age after being asked
an adult with a functioning moral integrity or even an ounce
of self-preservation with C's communication. He was trying to
get Cam Rainbolt. Are there any FBI? Yeah, that is like uh if
only he had Rainbolt. Okay. If only he had Rainbolt as an orbiter.
All right. Hey, look. Look at this picture. Where is she? Well,
that grass that grass is unique to like Kentucky, okay, this
Kentucky blueg grass. And you know, we really only see this level
of street sign in this
agents working in this goddamn country. Why are streamers doing
this investigation for them? It's even crazier than that. I don't
even think these are streamers that are doing this investigation
for him. These are members of his own community that aren't like
as um as brainbroken by the cult
that are literally saying like this is a bridge too far for me.
and they're the ones who have actually actively pulled themselves
out of the the the
state of of um the state of the cult that they were in. These
are all literally ex cult members. There are a lot of people
who used to call themselves orbiters, including some of the girls
that he actually uh shared the the uh Hassan Hassan doesn't know
about the plantation, guys. Hassan doesn't know about it. He's
unaware. He was there, but he was there when the plantation was
first developing. Okay. So, he got off he got off before it was
really a plantation at all. >> Um,
the revenge of
that called themselves orbiters. Like he basically designed this
like weird little for himself. And um these people were self-described
orbiters that were trying to, you know, generate some kind of
goodwill and and and clout off of like being associated with
him. And then when all of this stuff came out of him just like
filming himself both consensually and unconsensually without
telling the other person that he was filming them of having and
then sending these images
to random people online that he wanted to for some weird reason
and I cannot comprehend what that reason would even be. He uh
he he did all of this and a bunch of those people who were wronged
by him, including Pixie, which is one of the main victims here,
who just tweeted out he knew. >> Name drop
ago.
Okay, listen. There's some reason I I keep I'm going to keep
saying it. Why is this guy Why is this guy cruising not safe
for work Twitter with hashtags on Twitter? Why is he doing that?
Why is he doing that? Why? Why is he know why is he doing that?
It's very strange, isn't >> That uh is in a uh court case
with him right now for revenge. And their friends basically said,
"This is a bridge too far. We're severing our ties." Okay. >> Oh,
my ears are burning. >> Now, what's really interesting
about this is that one of the major generals in this battle
>> is Destiny's podcast co-host Dan Saltman. You might
know him as Diddy Dan or Dan Stalkman,
the guy who owns Redemption. >> Sorry. No. What? No. No.
I did not mean to hit that button. Hold on. I did not I did not
mean to hit that button. Diddy Dan. Diddy Dan. Diddy Dan. I That
was a mis That was a misclick. The guy who was so stupid that
he basically tanked the reputation of his company by making it
seem as though I was a client
of his company. And also simultaneously
that uh his company that's supposed to like sanitize your your
social media footprint was actually literally keeping blackmail
on people on their clients. Like that's the way he presented
his own company. That's what he was doing as far as marketing.
That person
also
that's listen there's uh Dan speaks out about the allegations
and orbiters. Is that today or something? Okay. Anyway, I I might
check it out. This is very interesting because yes, the a lot
apparently a lot of the Redact stuff like after the leaks happened
and [__] were like memeing about getting rid of like
bad getting rid of like stuff from crimes. I I believe there's
like the doctor disrespect stuff like, "Oh, should have used
Redact." They started memeing should have used Redact on a bunch
of stuff kind of like this.
Ah,
not good optics, guys. from my understanding, literally used
the the members of Destiny's cult that were actually criticizing
Destiny. He basically used private information of those people
to blackmail them into silence to blackmail them into submission.
Yes, that Dan Saltman that >> Wait, oh, is he talking about
me? Maybe he might be talking about me there. Interesting. H3H3
podcast, Ethan Klein's podcast, who is one of my major stalkers
who is actively trying to constantly get the ADL up my ass for
the crime of calling out Israel's genocide.
That guy is a sponsor of the H3H3 podcast. He basically damn
near writes most of Ethan Klein's context nukes and all this
[__] that he does. >> Oh, what a D. No, no,
no, no, no. I It's some logs from Spicy Chat that I think he's
probably referencing here. Uh, I do like, you know, you got to
appreciate people who want to write narratives of their own,
right? He's he's trying to web Ethan Klein in here to to attach.
And unfortunately, Ethan Klein has done everything to allow himself
to be attached to Destiny, right? Like, I don't think Ethan Klein
gets to go, "Oh, I've had nothing to do with Destiny." No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You both, you guys, you're attached now. Like, you just went
and ran this whole Hassan thing, right? And when people I think
people in his subreddit started saying like, "Wait, it's weird
to like compare this to Destiny. Wait, it's it's like kind of
crazy." I believe Pixie might have come in and said, "Hey, it's
weird to insinuate that like Hassan was getting pictures from
miners."
I think Pixie got banned from their subreddit for that. She got
downvoted and banned. At this point, I feel like that's there's
a lot of overlap there. And I I don't know if Ethan gets away
without some kind of tie. >> Did Ethan cover the drama
today? I don't know. It'd be interesting to know
Destiny's entire community because unfortunately
that community is almost completely that community almost completely
revolves around no like real decipherable worldview but instead
just a an insane anger that they feel towards me because I have
I some I guess wronged their favorite content creator Destiny.
It's interesting though because what they fail to recognize is
Destiny is
up his own career all the time. Like that's the reason that's
the reason why he's not like a household name. >> Let's
go. Let's go.
This is why, by the way, this is the number one reason that I
was telling you guys, if you like politics, go check out Pisco
because unfortunately for for everybody who likes Destiny and
thinks he's great at his job, he might be great at speaking.
That could be true. All right, but Destiny will constantly sabotage.
>> This is just anti-fan paraphernalia. I like diapers.
I offer to fly out miners. It's a gooner lifestyle, not >> Okay.
Thank you. Thank you for the donation. Destiny minor craft. Okay.
Thank you. So,
Destiny is good at speaking. He is He's funny. He's He's very
good at his job, right? But unfortunately, he will always put
himself above his movement. And you will always feel the pain
of having him uh put himself above his movement. Okay. The only
option to follow Destiny is to turn him into it's exactly like
Maga, right? He has to be it has to be a cult of personality
because he will always undermine his own movement. Always, always,
always for whatever his own ends are. Often, you know, degeneracy,
but not always. He'll always undermine his own movement and you
will get uh you'll get left holding the bag on that and you will
have to defend him if you want to keep going. Look at where counterpoints
is. Okay, counterpoints defending this guy. No matter what he
does, no matter what comes out about him, you will you will sit
there, your spine will become so flexible. All right? You'll
you'll basically become like an invertebrate. All right? You'll
have no spine left. That's the only option with him. It's why
you follow Pisco, you can follow something based on principles.
Super easy to understand.
But because he's so narcissistic and can never take accountability
for his own actions, he has basically created this world where
uh he can constantly say, "No, I'm in this position because Assan
lies about me or whatever." >> Oh. Oh man. Dude, I have
to find Where's the video of Dan coming on my stream and talking
about how, you know, everybody sends stuff around? Yeah, all
those people send stuff around. I think it's from December.
Oh, dude, there's so much here. There's so much
There's so much here. Yeah, I need that. I need that clip. If
anybody's listening, you got that video of Dan coming on my stream.
We're covering I believe that Scientology lady who's like losing
it on her boyfriend who cheated on her and Dan comes on and just
goes, "These people all send stuff around. It's all It's all
over the >> He might say, "Oh, I did this thing that's
wrong." But think about Hassan. He did something as well. >> And
that's been an ongoing cycle where he just basically uses me
as an offramp
>> Oh. Uh-oh.
That's crazy.
>> Uh, design me as like a primary villain for his community.
And a lot of his worldview unironically revolves around that.
Somehow finding a way to uh to directly contradict whatever the
I'm advocating for, even if under normal circumstances, he should
be in the same boat. I mean, he is the primary vector of the
hate Hassan content farming. That's where it came from. Before
that, it was just like random right-wingers.
He's the one who uh serialized that content and made a lot of
money off of it. Paid child support off of it for years. In any
case, he goes in the wall of shame alongside many of my other
ops that have been outed as criminals. >> Wait, what? Are
there a lot of them? Are there a lot of other ones? This seems
to be the primary one, but I don't know. Maybe there are. Was
Dr. Disrespect like a Hassan op or something? I don't know. >> Destiny
has an online career spanning nearly two decades at this point.
and he's expressed all throughout his career that underage girls
can can and do. He was over 30 years old when he started talking
to Rose. There is no defense. He was willfully ignorant. It's
worth noting that a member of a niche online forum made a post
early in the morning breaking down how Discord image links work
and said it could mean Destiny had been sharing images of Rose
around in a newly created channel around the time the leaks happen.
As far as I'm concerned right now, the Twitter DMs and email
story are compelling, but is all still alleged. There's no direct
evidence proving it right now from what I know. Right now, I'm
pretty convinced, but I'd like to see more backing up the story.
How does this keep happening to your enemies? It's because I
bring a vibe to the party that really don't like
the anti vibes that I bring around is something that uh pest
criminal
really do not jive with. And of course, >> I don't know
where he obtained this anti aura, but god damn, dude. It's
it's this is a crazy victory lap. This is a wild victory lap
right now. >> They they u declare me persona nongrada public
enemy number one. I don't know what the it is.
But yeah, I just super love sucking dick when I haven't for a
while. I get needy. Aha. Cute. [__] fetish. Yes.
Lol. Have you recorded any more BJC videos
>> he's soliciting
CS Sam from a 17-year-old in those logs. >> That see that
seems to be the case. >> But the story also doesn't necessarily
end there. I mean, he basically admitted to a lot of the stuff
and then went and turned around and hired Yeah. Allegedly he
was >> the the is Hassan going to drop the the logs on
the lawyer banger kilo tweet. Enough people are hitting me up
right now. I got to get this banger kilo tweet on stream. Okay.
Bunch of people saying got to pull this banger kilo tweet up.
Let's check it out. Let's check it out. What is this? What is
this? I said he's actually super open and above board with everyone
he interacts with. But even if he isn't, at least there at least
always has a clear consent established. But even if there's cases
where he didn't, then it was probably just a m miscommunication
and he would definitely feel remorseful about it. But even if
he doesn't, it's because the other women or the woman is probably
a who was doing the same thing. But even if that doesn't excuse
his own actions, it's not like he's going to just start lying
and doxing anyone who attacks him for those behaviors. But even
if he does do that, they probably deserve it because they're
trying to ruin his life. And it's totally a disproportion it's
totally not a disproportionate response. I mean, it's not like
he's in possession of CSAM or anything, right, bro? We like the
tweet. Like the tweet. We like the tweet. Dude, that is 2025
summed up so far. Exactly. Yes. That is just 2025 summed up precisely.
My god, man.
That's crazy.
>> Soliciting Cam. But he basically here one second. Is
Desty a POS or just mentally ill? POS. POS. POS. It's all intentional.
POS POS.
um turned around and and um >> how is there not an LSF
clip yet? I'm so confused, man. After Hassan's covering this,
there's not an LSF clip. Oh, what? There's no way. There's no
possible way there's no LSF clip after Hassan covered this on
stream. That's actually impossible. That's actually literally
Ela Klein to Hassan. Why did you bring me up? Why do you bring
me up? So, this is up here, right? So, obviously the Destiny
stuff has to be up here, right? New. We got a We got it. We got
it. We got it. We got a Hassan. Hassan Hassanabi. Hassanabi.
Hassanabi. No Hassanabi clips. Eh. Huh. That seems
borderline impossible. That seems totally impossible that Hassan
would be covering this live. By the way, we're behind on his
VOD. We're We're still We're 20 minutes away from where I open
this. We're probably like 30 40 minutes away from his live time
stamp. Right. He's covered this already. He's gone on. Oh, O.
No. O did post something and then delete it. Right. He deleted
it after he posted something then deleted it. That's That's crazy,
chat. That's That's crazy, chat. How how how
what? Dude, there's no way. Oh well.
>> Keep listening. >> At first, it seemed like he
wanted to apologize for it. At least on the revenge side of things
to the people that he had harmed. He admitted a lot of this stuff.
>> Dude, I'm so sorry. Okay, I'm so sorry to keep pausing
Hassan and interrupting him cooking right now. Okay,
but apparently we had uh Stale hop into DGG chat a couple hours
ago
and say, "What's the memes today?" DG. Hey, DJ DG. What's going
on? What guys? Hey, DG. What's the memes today? What's going
on today? Bro,
my my brother,
what is happening, dude?
imagine you have a cabal this powerful and you accuse me and
Queenman of cabaling. Okay, imagine,
imagine, imagine, imagine, imagine, imagine
you had a cabal like this that would just like sweep this massive
platform so nothing bad could get posted about you, right? And
you accuse me and Queen of of Cabaling. That's crazy. That's
wild. I'm just I'm going to keep refreshing cuz I know one of
these is going to get through. Somebody's watching my stream.
Somebody it I'm just going to keep refreshing. Okay. There's
no way. There's no way. There's no way. One more refresh. There's
still nothing.
There's still nothing. Okay. >> And then he went and he
hired Prince Andrew's law firm. And since he did do that, give
me two seconds
of undermining the victims over and over and over again because
at this point it's just like there's nothing going on
>> Like it's indefensible
and his reputation is understandably forever tarnished. So, all
he can do is basically attack and try to bring others down to
his level. But yeah, here he is demanding or uh or trying to
get her to fly in. I remember having a friend who would just
listen to him and literally talk about how you ripped him off
and like you used them for clout to jump start your career. Meanwhile,
he doesn't even watch him anymore. And every time I bring this
up, he just claims that he didn't know. Yeah. Rose was cited
for a traffic violation on July 21st of 2021. The details in
the court case mentioned her date of birth as 104, presumably
October 2004, without a date specified. I do want to say this
and I can't stress this enough. Dan 100% new and Destiny also
100% new. Keep in mind that currently Ethan Klein is making an
effort to >> Okay, I'm back. Holy, lots of stuff coming
in. What's going on? What's going on? Anonymous, thank you for
the gifted sub. Hold on. What What were all these? 17 months.
Thank you very much, Spruce Willis. And anonymous, thank you
for the gifted sub. Okay, dude. Uh, what did he say there? I
like the point he made or possibly Gat made about how Desty's
just like trying to smear victims. like he hired the smear lawyer
and then he just starts smearing victims. I have confirmation
from people that threads got deleted. So apparently threads on
this have already been deleted.
So LSF can talk about Hassan. They can do whatever they want
about Hassan, but about Destiny. No, no, no, no, no, no.
Amazing.
Uh, by the way, not the first instance of sweeping for a that
we're aware of from stale, right? Let's remember we just had
a whole controversy a while back where Stale was totally defending
this mod, right? So, not the first instance of sweeping for somebody
who likes people likes, you know, to get minors in underage,
sorry, minors in situations.
Very bizarre. You know, I personally would try to undo that kind
of reputation, but Stale's like just leaning hard into it. Very
interesting choice. Defame Assan and to downplay Destiny's action
by comparing them to Hassans. Do not let these three people,
Destiny, Dan, and Ethan, escape this. Ethan is fully aware of
the allegations against Destiny and is purposely helping him
bury it alongside Dan Saltman. These people are evil. Rose is
the only one of the multiple miners of Destiny has 100 throughout
the years. This
>> okay uh I believe these are direct KF posts that Hassan
is reading now. >> Says
again I will reiterate Willie Mack from the start said that he
wanted Destiny to get away with it and when he confronted him
finally about Rose, he put it in the video. >> I'm sorry.
I should also say though given what the other side does. Okay.
I I have a hard time like Yeah. I don't know, man. What how am
I supposed to have that much heat for Hassan when like realistically
Destiny's like trying to dox me? He continues to like go after
people. How am I supposed to Destiny reads these posts on stream
by the way? How am I supposed to have that much heat for Hassan
right now? Yo, Destiny's lie that you need age verification for
Tinder, which isn't true. Willie Mack was and has continued to
sweep for the from the start. What is this? Dan also 100% knew
the email that he sent to Bad Empanada was my confirmation. He
knows Rose underage, but he doesn't care and is actively helping
him hide it. Redact Dev is run by a sympathizer.
Ethan, I mean, it sounds like we need to know everybody that
was in that group chat, right? We need everybody who was in that
group chat. We need that whole group chat subpoena. Like, somebody's
got to get to work on this, right? That group chat is and and
realistically, if you're in there and you know about it, you
don't say anything. If they find out that she's 17 the whole
time and you bury that, do you not become like an accessory in
some way? is very interesting to think about. In >> Klein
currently is running the campaign to defame famous to downplay
Destiny's actions while sponsored by redact.dev.
These people are all in cahoots and coordinating one way or another.
And they don't even try to hide that they want to help Destiny
hide that he's a pedophile. If Assange still refuses to weaponize
against Destiny, then he's just as bad as him. He's actively
Dude. H
dude, this is crazy. I wonder if someone like Tony would give
you the names. Uh, I'm just going to move forward. I'm going
to pretend I didn't click on that. >> refusing to give
the to an actual predator who has been doing this exact thing
for more than a decade. Wait, what do you mean? How the is this
my fault? >> The child problem on Facebook is >> Oh,
this is a good one. Hold on. We'll feed We'll go We'll go We'll
weave. Okay, I'm going to weave. We're going to We're going to
take this. He's going to talk about this. I've got another instance
of him talking about this that's incredibly important to include.
Okay, there's a there's another instance of this that's incredibly
important to
>> people sending it in the messages. >> Sure. This
is the weirdest thing I'd ever discovered in my entire life.
There was a hashtag I don't remember what the hashtag was. There's
a hashtag on Twitter for underage people posting
>> where it was like TWWT or it was some hashtag but if
you clicked it it was a ton of girls like 15 16 someone was posting
full on with hashtags like holy
child holy it's like holy
guy it's like holy
this was in March this is March of 2023 March 25th, 2023.
Now, important to note that about a full year before this, he
had talked about this on stream a different time. Let's give
that a listen real quick. Is like, what was it? It was like I
think it was like 15.
She wrote 15 - 3 + 2 or something like that. Oh, wait, hold on.
Somebody saw it. Yeah, it was 8 + 12 - 5. And I'm like, "What
the fuck?" And I start scrolling through and I'm pretty sure
there is a tag on Twitter, MSNFW,
I think means
minor, not safe for work. And there's a whole bunch of people
on Twitter that are minors posting like what the true that is
very very very weird, isn't it? That there's a bunch of minors
on Twitter posting is not major. Yeah, I don't know if I'm on
like a list now, but yeah, it was super It's super weird and
creepy. >> Now, hold on. So, I keep seeing people say this.
This is already bad. Okay, but I've not seen So, he is he says
M NSFW NSFWTWT
is just not safe for Twitter. Okay, that would have adults and
whoever in it. But I'm going to point out that Destiny is aware
that miners post this stuff on Twitter. He is aware that is a
non-ageverified platform. There exists multiple ageverified
platforms to get nudes from to DM people on.
Why is he using Twitter for this? Now the data full group of
people and then there's like people interacting with him and
everything is like what?
>> So very importantly if you have he said NSF yeah yeah
I know Ozel but I know okay I know possibly that's thinking that's
clicking around in his head. Okay now on this one when he's first
aware of it the date is very important. Okay, now that that appears
to be January 2nd, 2022
within 3 months of this roughly, I believe he starts DMing Rose.
That's the like latest it could be. Okay, if the Twitter DM is
is right, it's about 3 months and 4 days. And so when you add
this together,
right, and his horror at this with the fact that,
okay, with the fact that
fact that he starts DMing Rose here, okay, he starts DMing Rose
here April 3rd, 2022. That's 3 months later, and he is aware
that he should be asking for ID. How
How do people let him skate on this, right? like he is expressing
his disgust that there are Yeah, I realize #nsfwtwt
is not it's not um it's not necessarily minors. Okay, but he
is aware that minor are posting. Oh, hello anonymous. Thank for
the gifted sub. He's aware minor
right? Ostensible discuss. True. Not real disgust.
Remember Destiny saying Molina was mature for her age? Yeah,
there's a lot of there's a lot of warning signs here, guys. There's
a lot of warning signs. Okay. You say, "Hey, I just need to make
sure you're 18." Oh, you can't do that. Well, that would be weird
if I had to if I had to see your ID. True. That would be weird.
I'm aware that there's not safe for I realize there are minor
posting on here. Do you want to go to Discord DMs? You want to
move this over to Discord DMs right now? Now, we aren't sure
that this exists. But even if this doesn't exist, he is aware
3 months because if if you're unaware of the timeline, I believe
7 days after this, 6 to 7 days after this is when he gets the
Pixie video and sends it to her, right? sends the pixie video
to Rose. And then a day after that, he hears about her getting
her braces off. Okay, that's the time progression. Now, I'm sitting
here
and I'm Yes, just writing something on paper is more than enough.
Okay, I believe you. Okay. Okay, I believe you. Now, again, we
don't have verification on this, but even if this weren't the
case, all right. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Even if this weren't the
case, even if this doesn't exist, it's still
that he would go to a platform that's not age verified, that
he's aware isn't age verified, that he has already said he knows
is not age verified, be skeptical about somebody's age,
and still connect with them for that's
That's nuts. Okay, that's enough for me. If I was somebody associated
professionally with this guy, you got to get away from him, right?
You got to get away from him. Oh, the followers at the top is
pretty close. Yeah, this was taken recently.
Oh, right. Well, this would have been taken in January, right?
I think this would have been taken in January or sorry, December
or January.
Yeah, one one day old account apparently. Which makes me think,
how many people was he messaging on Twitter? It's a one day old
account. I wonder if he's going to get dropped by on America.
Well,
let me just say that I do not believe that a lot of this is unexpected
by anybody. The people who follow Destiny are going to go, "This
wasn't unexpected." And the people who hate Destiny are going
to go, "This is not unexpected." So, for people professionally
associating with him, I have no idea how little due diligence
they have to do to make sure that that works right for them.
Anybody doing their due diligence should be like, "No, this guy's
radioactive." Does Arerodite like pickles? Well, pickled Nicholas,
if you if you aren't unaware, okay, if you could combine I think
Destiny's just a Roblox fan. If you guys aren't aware, Roblox
launched their 17 plus dating service. All right, maybe Destiny's
thinking, hey, if Arerodite can get that ranch for weward boys
going and I can groom enough minors from Twitter, we can start
our own underage dating service. We'd be matchmakers, right?
Troubled girls posting their underage. troubled boys who have
problems with substance abuse. It's like a match made in heaven
between the two of them, right, dude. It's uh that's crazy. The
Jtock clip is gone. No way.
Apparently, there was a thread. Apparently, there was a thread
and it is already Oh, it doesn't seem to be gone yet. Hold on.
Hold on. Deleted post. Oh, maybe it is deleted. They seem to
be downloading things, guys. They don't want it to get through.
They don't want to They don't want stuff to get through. They
don't want it to happen. All right. But it see I mean, it seems
to be there. I see it there. I I can't really check in on them
or they could remove them ostensibly for brigading. So, we're
going to be a little chill with it. They started that tour knowing
well about Pixie situation. At least they could not blame ignorance
since Pac-Man dropped. I don't believe they can claim ignorance.
And I believe that Destiny's smear campaign against people was
very effective. He's very good at it. Uh Andy B also very good
at it. Right. They've tried to convince everybody that this is
all made up, that none of it's true, and none of the underlying
facts have changed. None of them. The comment that got nuked
was like, "Internesting. We know about this for two hours, but
no threads on LSF yet." Well, we'll see if they're We'll see if
LSF threads start. We'll see. All right. Okay. We've gone through
this. Hassan's watched this. We We watched the follow-up clip.
Yeah. The the not safe for work Twitter stuff. That's very scary.
Okay. Jacob's banned from LSF. >> Awkward problem on Facebook
is people sending it in the messages.
>> This is the weirdest thing I'd ever >> You're
replaying it, Hassan. Move on. >> How the did he know that?
is is strange. >> It is like what was it? It was like I
think it was like 15. Oh, there there's the other one. Okay,
there's the other one. I just got to highlight this Ozel clip
really or Ozel comment really quickly. So crazy that this deranged
70-year-old might be giving Trump a third term. Guys, Trump's
the president right now. Okay, Trump is the president. America
is under threat of fascism. Why are you paying attention to destiny
being a Okay, why would you pay attention to that? Do you want
Trump to have a third term? Is that what you
She wrote 15 - 3 + 2 or something like
>> Oh, wait. Hold on. Somebody saw it. Yeah, it was 8 +
12 - 5. And I'm like, what the [__] And I start scrolling
through and I'm pretty sure there is a tag
on Twitter, MNSFW,
I think means minor, not safe for work. And there's a whole bunch
of people on Twitter that are minors posting like
what the It was not major. Yeah.
Yeah. Oh. Oh, hold on. NSFW Twitter. The NSFW side of Twitter,
even though it's supposedly 18 plus, it's full of 15-year-olds
with 18 plus DNI in their bios and barely 18year-olds looking
to start Only Fans accounts from May 7th, 2021. Oh, that makes
it so much worse.
And just so you know, Rose did have this in her bio. I think
Hassan might pull it up. Supposed to be 18 plus full of 15y olds
with 18 plus DNI in their looking to start only fans accounts.
What the
>> is this [__] >> This is these are
all those are all her tweets. Okay, they all had the tag. That's
all her tweets trying to start her like uh her. Okay. >> When
you feel like the internet is a depraved place
full of freaks, >> it gets worse. It gets worse than you
would ever think. I didn't. >> Okay. 18 plus DNI means
if you're over 18, don't interact. This [__] Anyway,
>> um,
nuke Twitter. Nuke Twitter. This is your ops, brother. Horrible
people. I know. But the reason why I brought this up is because
yes, as uh, why did Destiny make Hassan win like this? Wait.
God, why did I say that? Why did I say it like that? Whoops.
Hold on. I'm focusing up. Not enough caffeine today. Why did
Destiny make Hassan win like this? Okay. Why did Destiny make
Hassan win like this? Hassan won. Hassan just objectively won.
Like, it's over. It's over.
It's over. It's completely over. But, you know, I'm very hopeful
that this isn't the uh the end of Bad Breaks for Destiny, okay?
We don't don't don't worry, guys. For us, it's not over. For
Destiny, it's over. But for us, it's not over. We get to look
forward to hopefully some federal authorities looking into this.
Okay? That would be that would be fantastic. Realistically, I'm
not like dead. I'm not done yet. Okay, I need to know. Wait,
what happened? We're going to get into it. Forgotten Jones, we're
getting into it now. Go back in the stream. We're uh we get to
watch. Okay, we just get to watch. I'm just That's what I'm That's
what I'm hoping for. I'm hoping for Okay, the feds the feds talked
to him apparently. I'm hoping that there's an investigation from
those those feds who visited him. Okay. And they're they're looking
into this Rose person that the previous Twitter thread also was
pointing to as that previous Twitter thread was also pointing
to Yes. Dan Stalkman, Dan Saltman, who's Destiny's podcast co-host,
sponsors the H3H3 podcast. Now, post October 7 in the last couple
of months, they basically became the only so JJ IU GG78N.
I cannot confirm that this happened for sure. Okay.
especially not the underage nudes part, but I've got a couple
little tidbits
that go around this that do lend credence to it, although we
do not know for sure. All right, they do lend credence. We don't
know for sure. So, it appears there was a group chat made. It
appears there's there is some group chat that exists. It appears
that
the pictures of Rose that Destiny leaks later, all right, cuz
we haven't even gotten to this main part of the story yet. Okay,
an absolutely massive part of this story is that
2 months ago, sorry, 3 months ago when they hadn't found when
the people who kind of look who who a log Destiny had not found
Rose, Destiny decided to go to DGG chat and talk [__]
about them and taunt them, the people in his KF thread and say
they suck at looking things up and post pictures of Rose. What
he unknowingly did was give away the fact that the channels he
was posting those Discord attachments from were created December
3rd or December
All right. So, apparently there are Discord rooms or group chats.
So, either rooms and discords or group chats that were created
December 3rd, December 4th about a week a week after the leak
where he was posting the full picture of of Rose, right? Like
uh pictures of her face and stuff. And then he sent those attachments
to his DG chat and said, "Hey guys, just so you know, about three
days afterwards."
Okay, sure. Three, four days afterwards. So then he sent those
pictures in DG chat a couple months later and said, "Hey, Ka,
you guys suck at doxing people. Bet you can't find this girl."
He was like mocking them. So he sent the pictures of this person
who appears to be have been a minor at the time that he was sending
these pictures. And then he said, "Good luck. Good luck finding
her. And these pictures were pivotal in them actually finding
the person. I'm not joking. This is actually the case. We'll
see. I don't know. I'll go through my thread just really quickly
to see if um if Assan catches up on it. Okay. Give me one second.
Go to my thread on this. We'll just read it. I'll show you. I'll
show you the the messages cuz the messages are bonkers. Like
it's act it is totally bonkers the way he sets this up. Okay,
let's take a look here. Let's take a look. Let's take a look.
So, for those wondering, those wonder I always misspell in my
big tweets. I had I I rush tweeting this me. For those wondering
how the information about Desty's underage sex partner was found
today, look no further than at the Omni Liberal himself. In May,
he decided to taunt his Kiwi Farm openly while providing additional
private information to them. Logs read bottom up. So, he's responding
to somebody in DG chat. May 28th, 2025. It's funny because they
think I'm hiding stuff about Rose since she's underage. The only
reason I haven't actually mentioned her about much about her
is because I know it makes those dig harder. So, he posts this
picture, which is a picture of Rose. Okay. If they want more
to go on, so he's literally giving them stuff, more stuff to
go on. Now, I don't know if this was her college or not. I'm
actually not 100% on this, but he says she went to blank college.
Good luck. So, when Destiny says when Destiny talks about playing
footsies with Kiwi Farms, make no mistake, he is the person who
plays footsies with Kiwi Farms, okay? He is the person who does
that. It's not me. It's not Queen. It's not anybody else. He
is the person who does that. He is directly taunting them to
try to dox this girl. Uh I will say from file attachment names,
it seems obvious that she was under a uh it seems obvious that
he received this picture when she was a minor. So he's posting
pictures of her as a minor. I Oh, I might even describe it. Is
a you know, I don't want to describe it, but I will. It is the
It is the minor appearing as a minor, I believe, wearing just
a DG t-shirt. There's nothing um no no genitalia or anything
shown, but I believe they're just wearing a DG t-shirt, like
a Destiny Gnome t-shirt, which realistically I I'll give him
this. Okay, that may be the most onbrand picture that's ever
been made. So, I will give him that, but it is disgusting. Okay,
we have to disavow. It is disgusting, but it might be the most
onbrand thing I've ever seen. Uh it is not feds. It is uh it
is the people he is taunting. It is the it is precisely the people
he is taunting who found this person because of this additional
info shared. Uh he didn't stop there by the way. Okay, he didn't
stop there. Uh KF's ability he went he continued to monologue
KF's ability to investigate anything is super pathetic. I thought
it was some crazy investigator, but now I realize it was just
no life obsessively stalking all of my social media that allowed
someone to do it. Easy to do when you live on permanent disability.
Also, I never said that pic posted was of me. It was a a pic
they sent from their school. Supposedly, they were working on
an blank. This is the degree. She's This is her degree program
that he's saying now. Good luck. Smiley face. Also, one more
pick. I'm not in this one either, if you can't tell. Good luck.
Okay, good luck. And he posts another picture of her. Okay,
sorry. I'm done skitso posting in here. Good luck. He posts multiple
images of them, the name of their college or her college, and
what he recalls to be her degree program. He intentionally set
this woman up to be docs in the exact manner he constantly lies
about myself or queen doing. Very sick guy. Very, very sick guy.
Okay. The person would not have been doxed but for this additional
information provided by Destiny. Why would he do this? It boggles
the mind. I actually and realistically, I mean, people say, "Oh,
he's a psycho. He's got a fetish." Honestly, I I don't I still
don't understand. I still don't get it. I I don't get it. Now,
how counterpoints can defend Destiny coming into his DG chat
in May of 2025, posting a picture of a minor, and then telling
KF, "Try to dox her. Try to dox her, providing a bunch of personal
details about her. How counterpoints or aerodite or any of those
people could sweep for this is
beyond me.
I don't know how they can do it. I already didn't know how they
could do it, but this one is. This one takes the cake. This one's
beyond the pale." Okay. It's It's crazy. This is what this will
be the line. I guess it's not so late spoken yet. I don't believe
so. I don't believe so. We're going to get back to the group
chat stuff because I believe there will be a little bit more
even supporting the the creation of the group chat. We have the
pictures um pictures that we talked about. Okay. The pictures
of Rose that are here that basically when you link an attachment,
you can look and see the channel it was linked in and you can
see when that channel was created. So, these are created at the
same timing as the the email that went to that went that people
posted. Okay, that email that people posted. Um, it fits that
timeline. Does Dan have a daughter and he is a Destiny ally?
I believe he does. I he invoked it during the forethought thing,
right? Did he not invoke it during the forethought thing? I could
have sworn he did. Cooney, we don't know yet. We don't even know
that a group chat for sure existed on this. We don't know if
it was created. We actually don't know. Well, sorry. We do know
something was created where he either started DMing somebody
or he created a group chat or a channel where it was happening.
I believe he'd lean towards channel unless it was maybe with
a like DMs with a anonymous account or something. Let's not Oh,
I'm sorry. Yeah, you guys could say I don't need to talk about
it. I'm saying that Dan has virtue signaled about how he needs
to make the world a better place for his daughters. He has done
that. So, you can say let's not, but he has absolutely virtue
signaled to win a petty spiteful argument with forethought. And
so when I say that same thing that he has tried to make the world
a better place for his daughters and he's still friends with
Destiny, [__] you for saying I shouldn't bring that
up. [__] you and [__] Dan. Okay, I'm
not going to go at length and talk about it. I don't have to.
I don't want to. But I am going to bring up that he did that
because it's absolutely relevant to this point. We love Dan here,
folks. We don't love Dan. We don't love Dan. We're not huge fans.
We don't love Dan anymore. Okay. Okay. That's it for this one.
Let's get back to Hassan and then once we're done with Hassan,
we've got a couple other things to watch here. Okay. >> Sponsor
of the podcast. I'm I'm pretty sure that's why you see that little
redactive button, the Ethan Klein button that he hits when he
says some as a 40-year-old man who can't control his mouth. That
button is sponsored by Dan Salman. Dan Salman has a podcast with
Destiny. Dan Salman has done numerous brigades spamming false
information to advertisers to try to take out to try to implement
an ad apocalypse on Twitch, claiming that Twitch has a deep rooted
anti-semitism problem. Of course, Dan Saltman streams on kick.
So does Destiny. And I think we all know that >> Oh, come
on, man. Don't Don't put Destiny on kick. Come on, man. Oh, come
on. Come on, brother. Come on, brother. Don't do that. >> Looks
like anyway,
>> brother. Man, >> Ethan Klein knows all this. He
knows that Dan Saltman is uh has a podcast with Destiny is Destiny's
like general basically second in command and he tries to actively
make it seem as though he's not in cahoots with Destiny and his
community when in fact they get most of their notes from that
community. Right now there's probably thousands of people watching
on Destiny's website trying to find the next thing that they
can clip out of context and post on live stream fails. the popular
subreddit that was once popular for live stream fails and now
is just uh a
an entire subreddit dedicated to just me.
Hassan triples down on calling Hilo a valid target of violence.
Los Rton employs a Hassan strategy during a League of Legends
game. I don't even know what this this even means. I think they're
just trying to memeify it. If you look at some of the top posts,
XC calls out Hassan for brainwashing his audience regarding the
Israel Palestine conflict. The reason why the subreddit is so
active. Oh, it's uh that thread's being hardcore brigaded, it
looks like. Okay, this is a situation where evidence needs to
be shown ra uh rather than having more claims of insan for people
who never show proof and have obvious agendas. That's not what's
happening here. That's not what's happening here. Oh, it's being
downvoted into oblivion. We'll see. We'll see if it makes it.
Okay, this is this is going to be their their thing. They're
going to go, "Oh, we allowed We allowed clips on this. We allowed
clips on this. We totally allowed clips on this, guys. guys,
we allowed them >> when it comes to
is because it's owned now and completely controlled by one of
Destiny's orbiters
who by his own admission once famously ran for I guess a company.
>> Oh, not a company. Sorry. Once ran for a competition
that is called like DJer of the year. >> Oh boy. Oh boy.
>> They've used the live stream subreddit.
>> Can we just go back to this thread real quick and just
click through? What do we think's going to happen if we um if
we click through here? Spoiler alert. I know what's going to
happen. We click through. We click through. Submitted. R/ Destiny.
R/ Destiny. R/ Destiny. Oh, we've arrived at and trans issues.
The podcast is healing. Interesting. Interesting. Oh boy. Oh
boy. It's just >> The past couple of years at this point
to actively try to create and manufacture drama. And in the process
of trying to actively manufacture and create drama, they basically
destroyed the subreddit, ironically enough. But this is it. That's
dance salt man. Why do they photoshop Dan's face? I I'm pretty
sure that's like clearly Dan photoshopped there, but photoshopped
in a way that just makes it look weird.
I'm pretty confident that's photoshopped.
That's photoshopped in like a big skinny way. Like that like
a subtle way where it's like No, that's definitely photoshopped.
They like move Dan's face like down his face or something. I'm
almost positive, dude. No way. No, that's slightly photoshopped.
I'm telling you >> this is not what he looks like. I think
this is just like >> Okay, this is photoshopped. >> Still
is not photoshopped, though. And that is the guy who runs LSF.
Former Twitch staff of four years. Stale 2000, I believe is his
username. And on his YouTube page, we found a video of him petitioning
to be
the uh Yeah, if you do top and then click by week, look, look
at the top post on the subreddit. Owned and operated entirely
by Destiny's mod. The guy on the right is not actually photoshopped.
The guy on the left is >> Dude, he's just going in on stale
out of >> Invited to the streamers because AT&T didn't
want him there. Assumper says that Hila Khan is a valid military
target. No repercussions. One as gold clip. Hassan triples down
on calling Hila a valid target of violence. Destiny calls out
push for allowing a sampire to run a terrorist recruiting platform
on their site. Destiny reacts to Hassan's viral Hila client comments.
Hassan responds to Mr. Beast and XQC and aid and making fun of
him for not donating. Which, by the way, this one was interesting.
It's a two-minute video.
son's going offated the first day to Mr. Beast's uh to Mr. Beast
charity. This is the last week. Does this look normal to you?
Son throwing up a popular Turkish
Helilin's response. Helila Klein response [__] statement
in which he endorsed and justified violence and murder. You would
think you would think
if this had any sort of real motion and it wasn't just like a
flesh designed
for for uh tarnishing and slandering Destiny's enemies.
>> Yeah, I did donate. I donated the first day. I just
did it quietly. Um anyway, >> wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What? Okay. Okay. Now, Hassan, let me just say he could go he
could go top off uh Pixie thing, right? I think Hassan, be that
guy. Be the hero. Okay. Make sure that Pixie has the money to
keep forcing Destiny to get Andrew Breler to write briefs for
him at $2,000 an hour. Whatever that guy charges, okay? Make
sure Pixie's got the money to keep doing it. I trust you, Hassan.
I trust you. I trust you. Get it done. >> I donated the
first day. I just did it quietly.
Um, anyway, active campaign on ready to discredit criticism of
propaganda. Yep. This isn't the first time this has happened.
I mean, this has been ongoing for a couple years at this
So, when you wonder in the wild, when you when you wander around
in the wild and you see someone who has an opinion over me about
me that you cannot comprehend where they arrived at that conclusion
from, it could. >> So, it's just a full-on Hassan sip now.
Sad. I think this is ironic. be any number of different places,
but
it's usually from one of these groups that have never stopped
doing this.
Journalists are aware of it. Journalists that have covered Gamergate
are aware of it. They say this is like gamer actually. True.
Pickled Nicholas. Okay. I'm just I'm just from one Destiny Alog
to another, you know, real recognized real Hassan's doing a fantastic
job, isn't he? Don't we don't we love Hassan for the job he does?
Aloging Destiny. Okay. He He sees Destiny. He sees what he's
like. We love Hassan here. Okay. If for nothing else, just this
part
>> on steroids, but directed at one person instead of like
a bunch of different targets. It's the exact same for a lot of
these guys who never grew out of that Gamergate style of of behavior
online. >> He's just reading stuff from KF. And what's
the problem with that? We're worried about Destiny suing him
for copyright infringement. I believe Destiny does have the patent
on reading KF posts directly on his stream. So, you know, it
might be a problem. This is what uh this is what they busy themselves
with. Yeah. Slate deleted the DDR of the year video, but it's
of course it was on his >> I'm stale 2000.
>> Yeah, it was on his uh YouTube and when we found it
when we found it, he deleted it. But this is the guy who runs
the LSF >> and I'm running for DGER of the year on December
the 3rd. In this video, I'm going to be talking about how all
of my opponents are way worse than me using facts, logic, and
most importantly, evidence, as in chat logs. Here, Albert FCB
is asking people to gift him subs. A real DGER buys his own subs
in the month. How did Hassan find this? I thought Stale deleted
this video of November. Fitz spammed the >> Anyway, that's
all you need to know uh about this dude. This is not satire.
This is like literally their own little inter community fun that
they engage in. So, not only that, but like I said, Dan Saltman
has played a formative role in silencing the criticism that's
coming internally from the community after Destiny's numerous
crimes were unveiled and people started questioning Destiny and
people started attacking him. People started people felt like
he was maybe not such a good guy. It even caused some of these
people to actually reflect on the way that they have covered
me as a matter of fact. They were like, "If I can't trust this
guy on this, maybe he was just lying about Hassan."
Oh, again ears burning >> entire time. Some of them actually
arrived at that conclusion and realize that they were lied to.
But there are those who are obviously still very much firmly
in the cult and do everything in their power to either try and
sweep this kind of stuff so that other content creators are oblivious
to it or
actively try to attack me because in their minds I guess they
think as long as we can undermine Hassan then people will eventually
love Destiny which is not how these things work. >> These
top are food shops in Ardite. That's rough man. I can't wait
for the food chops commentary on this stream. Okay, just watching
watching me in any context. Apparently, food chops is just down
every time. I honestly if food chops gave critical commentary
in any way, I'd have no problem with it. But they give stardust
commentary right where they don't pay attention. They just play
a video game and they just let that [__] play. Like
it's totally
the whole time.
Probably something should be done. Okay, probably >> very
sad state of affairs overall. >> Sorry. Shouldn't Shouldn't
leave that. shouldn't leave that unspecified.
Okay, probably something should be done as in like I should actually
complain about that to somebody. >> There was also another
video I wanted to show from Dan if someone has it. >> Well,
I don't know about that video. I don't know what Hassan's video
was, but I do have a video of Dan coming around at some point.
I believe in December.
Okay, I believe in December.
>> You guys are like forcing me to sweep for Steve. Listen,
>> no, do it. Go for it. Like I seem forced to do this
frequently. Okay, first of all, okay, I would say that I'm pretty
confident that everyone
>> that everyone
who was featured in these videos also sent videos of them and
other people as well. Kind of planting the planting the seeds
there. Kind of planting some seeds.
Planting some seeds, you know. I believe I I believe I told Dan
to shut up when he was talking about this. I'm not sure. I think
I did after this.
Not 100%. >> But nobody talks about that. >> Nobody
talks about that. Nobody talks about how all of these people
are just like totally insane.
Nobody's Nobody's out here talking about that. Why is nobody
talking about that? The pre- sweep was crazy on this one. All
right. Where he's like talking to everyone in his community in
Destiny's community being like, "You're all hypocrites. If I
see you calling out Destiny, I'm going to do everything in my
power to take you out." He has already doxed numerous people.
There's even doxed people that are like fan editors of mine on
Twitter
>> weaponizing the DMCA claims to his advantage. They're
basically just they
>> Your hands aren't clean. You said we love Dan at the
time. We didn't Hey, was the gun to your head? Was the doxing
gun to your head place or is the doxing gun to my head and other
people's head? Okay. We love Dan and we were terrified of Dan.
Okay.
You put that gun up to your head, brother. Okay, put that gun
up to your head and see what happens. >> Basically, they're
just doing Gamergate, but for one dude, and they've latched on
to the pro-Israel side of the argument
because they know that there are at least like groups that are
just as crazy that have some level of institutional power
that can also be beneficial allies in their cause.
my fellow uh orbiters or co-workers. If you're some one of my
co-workers out there and uh you're making a little bit of a strong
statement about how much you condemn Destiny and everything else,
um you better not let me [__] mind you doing something
else and signing some other bull for someone else. All this is
just virtue signaling bully. Okay, it's like because it's like
oh god sharing nudes. Okay, I'm out of here immediately, right?
Like right everyone is using this as a as a jumping off point
to like try and make their side win. Don't let me capture you.
Like that's the only way he analyzes this stuff is like making
their side win. This dude is like 60 years old by the >> He
tweeted a list with me on it and I bet Dan would dox me if he
could. Danny sucks and hates cars. I don't know if he hates cars.
Teeny tiny Tony. But I do know that a lot of people are on those
list. Okay, on that list. Is Skizobbot around?
I kind of want to go and just say there's something funny about
that list tweet. And maybe if you guys remind me and I get Skitsbot
to message me. I think I messaged them. Hold on. I there's something
funny there that I'm just going to I'm going to talk about if
I can, but we'll watch this for a second, man. Like, what the
do you mean?
It's about having an incredibly toxic >> Sorry. I'm going
to also restart this so we get the VOD updated. The list tweet.
Yeah, where um Destiny listed out his clip like Queen's Clippers
and was like, "Oh, look at this guy trying to shape narratives
with his clippers and right that one. Why is this not loading?
Hello. Can this load? Hello, Twitch, please. Thank you." is about
having an incredibly toxic force in online political discourse
that is basically never held to account, never held accountable
for any number of different horrifying things that he does. The
metric that is applied to someone like myself is so distorted.
I get quote unquote canceled or smeared
for things that I don't believe, for things that I've never said,
for false framing of things that I'm talking about. Meanwhile,
if I were to say even a fraction of the awful that Ethan Klein
says or that Destiny says in any number of different streams
that they've done, I would of course be cancelled a million times
over by these guys, ironically enough. But this one is
extraed up because what he's talking about here is a distribution
of revenge while in the process of trying to solicit allegedly
>> non-conentual distribution of uh
images >> and from a minor
in 4K being a virtue signaling that uh you know felony capture
that that event from any of these people. Uh I will I will [__]
destroy you if that's the case my fellow uh orbiter. Uh, no.
He didn't. He didn't do this. Captain Timu. Captain Teemo. Yeah,
he didn't do that. >> Why is Dan trying to sound like Destiny?
I don't know, dude. Cuz he's [__]
I feel like it's given his life meaning, I guess. But that's
the main sponsor. That's the That guy is the main sponsor.
What is this? Dan Saltman, sponsor of the H3 podcast, is found
in Discord dedicated to spreading lies and stalking Hassan's
family. Turkey backs Palestine and they don't >> Oh, he's
got this whole thing up here like Jesus. >> It was just
a funny theory and I think people would latch on to this without
a second thought. So, if you don't care about hard proof, then
I think this would cause a panic with enough people to get some
real movement on it. >> Just going to throw it out there,
guys. Nico Sam dropped out of all of this like months ago. Okay,
Nikos dropped out of all of it. He is not involved anymore. Don't
Don't do anything with Niko Sam's Nikosam's just he's a he's
a good boy. Okay, he didn't do nothing. Just leave him alone.
He ran. He's >> I found a book his dad wrote. It's the
limited free version and in Turkish, but maybe something could
be extracted from this. Step one is to confirm it's his dad.
Step two to answer the question, who is his dad? This is >> That
was my alarm clock. I don't know why that went off, but
>> the unspoken side
of what I have to deal with on a daily basis. what these guys
claim I'm doing to them, ironically enough, is exactly what they're
doing to me. I've never done this to any >> Assan is speaking.
You guys just want to ask me what the alarm was. The alarm is
uh the Nokia ringtone. If you've watched ReZero, it's the Nokia
ringtone on his phone when he's setting up to go fight the whale
and it's the song that plays. I really like the first season
of Re:Zero. Okay. I thought it was good.
uh the second, third, fourth, all the other seasons suck completely.
First season was good though. The the whale that was awesome.
>> No, any of these guys I don't give a [__]
enough to do anything like this and I think it's it's repulsive
to do things like this to begin with. The double standard
is so glaringly obvious.
>> Can you imagine if I was in a Discord server stalking
Ethan's family members or if I was like sponsored by a guy
who was doing that? Now, that would be a Philip DeFranco video,
let me tell you. >> Why is he constantly talking about
Ethan? Because
he gets all of his negative uh like negative adjacent like mapped
onto him. And he's doing the same in reverse, right? I'd say
Ethan after the whole like, oh, Hassan's
Ethan did a segment, his subreddit kind of watched it as like,
oh, Hassan's just as bad as Destiny because Hassan used to like
open up his phone and there were nudes on it and he let people
use his phone or he get like Snapchats and he would open them
without caring who could see his phone and they tried to equate
these things, the people in the subreddit. Okay, very gross.
>> In the process of defending Israel,
>> Ethan Klein got actually uh cancelled by his own audience.
People yelled at him a lot because of the way he was presenting
this issue that was a black and white issue. It's genocide. His
own audience didn't want him to do it. They couldn't fathom it.
They couldn't believe it. And slowly but surely, he just chipped
away at the remaining progressive people in his fan base. And
in that process, he never let it go. He just assumed that it
was because I was like brainwashing his fans into hating him.
Okay. Falsely smearing him. >> Okay, hold on. Hold on.
We're uh we're getting super off track. We'll see if he brings
it back. Okay, we'll see if he brings it back. >> That
I was a terrorist over and over again. A terrorist mouthpiece,
a terrorist propagandist, one that should potentially face legal
repercussions by the Trump administration. Now, in the process,
he claimed that child protected >> Okay, CPS. Hold on.
>> Then came >> I get it. >> I I'm going to
skip through. We'll see if he gets to more stuff. >> I
don't think Ethan has once condemned the Islamophobic attacks
that I've received, especially because he himself is unironically
responsible for view. I see them as a threat asan's
not wrong about some of this stuff, but
>> sponsor confirre
take a look when you also get around to
>> Oh, this is going back to his his uh the thread or sorry
the the discord. Here we go. Here we go. >> A content creator
equals random internet comment. No, I mean that's that's it's
not equivalent either. And of course, if you want to understand
what this kind of like insanity
leads to, look, it's him 100% confirmed. One sec. I got it. Old
man linger. Take a look when you also get around to it. >> Uh
man, the old man lingerie guy. Okay, that guy is going to have
some That guy does a
lot of doxing. Okay, a lot of doxing and I don't think he gets
any comments for it really. That guy does a lot of >> Goes
through life and details his sister Hassan's mom talking about
Dan Saltman, >> sponsor of the H3H3 broadcast through redact.dev
dev in a discord dedicated to stalking my family. That is Ethan
Klein's only sponsor. What the are we >> I will say I do
believe there is some point here that I realize a lot of people
just think like, oh, why is he roping Ethan into this? No, I
think Ethan knows what the allegations are. I think Ethan's got
to be pretty aware and I think Ethan is willing to have the association
with Destiny and Dan regardless of those allegations. I think
that's a calculated decision on his part. I don't like that decision,
right? And I think that is a good thing to point out. I do think
that he's okay with that association. I do think he he believes
either he's complicit in that he must believe some spin they've
put on it, right? That it's all made up or something. And he
he wants the anti-hazan information, so he's willing to maintain
that connection. I think that's detestable. I don't think that's
a crazy thing to say. Here we go again with the drama.
Resident Liber brother, do you think it's drama that there is
a Discord server dedicated to stalking my family? Are you insane?
What is drama, dude? Bro, one of these days I'm gonna get killed
and these guys are going to be like, "L Hassan tuning in from
the hospital talking about how his how he got
L drama, bro. Put the news in the bag, little bro. >> Stop
complaining about getting Hassan. Stop complaining. Oh, I don't
have the >> I saw this on my on my community page. >> We're
better now." >> I said, "If I get mercked by an adult wearing
a color block pastel hoodie made for children, I'm haunting everyone
involved for generations."
These were some of the comments under Ethan Klein's video. Nah,
I think in this case he needs to be taken out. Hassan, that's
a member. Hassan cannot threaten our queen and expect to get
away with it. Whatever happens to him now will be welld deserved.
May he sleep with one eye open. He has gravely mistaken our fan
base for not being dangerously insane when it comes to protecting
our own. It's coming, dude. Oh, Jesus Christ,
dude. I think and they did this intentionally. Like Hassan did
not do this in the other direction. Hassan did not make threats
like this, right? It's not the same. It's not the same on the
threat part at all
for him. What about Hassan? He doesn't have anywhere near the
protection he will need. I've watched him up close plenty for
when I need to. The war has begun. Please, someone has to off
Hassan. People should never have associated with these far-left
psychos like Hassan. There has twisted mega cultist just in a
different ideological
>> Hon's fan base 100% does this as well. The difference
is flu. There's no way to interpret Hassan's comments as being
like um like advocating for violence against him. I would say
with with Destiny, uh it's very obvious when he says I think
you could totally justify Hassan based on this. It's pretty obvious
what he means, right? Going the other direction now. And I think
when Ethan lies about what Hassan says, when he says he's like
directly called for for Ela to be or directly called her like
a valid military target, I think that's pretty too. It's like
very different. Also similar ones as well. Disgusting.
Yeah, there's more. more. It's not just those three comments.
This is just like some choice words from under the video. A video
that Ethan Klein has changed the uh the thumbnail and title of
a million times at this point, including uh as far as I understand,
his last version of it was just death threat. >> What are
you pulling up, son? >> His own son, Nathan Bonnel, our
>> We're not going We're not going through Nathan stuff,
so we'll see if we can skip forward. Uh Asmin Gold being anti-Semitic.
I think that's that might be it for the uh the Destiny stuff
here. That might be it. We might we might be through this whole
segment
and get on to the other stuff. Okay, there's going to be some
other stuff that will be funny. It will be fun.
All right, I might show off
some other logs and stuff. We'll see. Oh, also we have that whole
Connor stream. I forgot we have that whole Connor stream to go
through, dude.